[Music]
dylan is with us in gainesville florida
hey dylan what's up
great how are you doing today dave
better than i deserve how can i help
well i got a couple big life changes
coming up i'm graduating college uh this
may with a degree in computer science
and i have a job offer in florida for
after i graduate uh however uh my
girlfriend wants to sort of live abroad
for a bit before settling down
and another thing that might help with
context is i received a half a million
dollar
inheritance from my grandparents so i
have a little bit of flexibility but i
was just wondering what advice you have
so you're trying to figure out how to
talk to your girlfriend about this that
you don't want to move overseas
i'm interested in moving overseas
however i'm just scared about i enjoy
the safety of staying in uh you know
having a job offer i was just wondering
well if it's your girlfriend it's one
thing if it's your fiance or your wife
it's another
okay girlfriends you just send them
overseas it's fine
fiances and wives we don't want to be
separated from
am i wrong
i mean if she wants to go over there and
live that's fine she just puts at risk
the fact that you might find somebody
else while you're hanging out there in
florida i mean that's how that works
um
but i'm not readjusting my life
plan for a girlfriend
i wouldn't if i were you anyway i'm
certainly not i don't i have one
girlfriend i've had the same one for 40
years as my wife so but uh i'll adjust
my life for her uh because she's my wife
but i'm not a just
i would not suggest there's a better way
of doing a young person or an old person
adjust their life for someone that you
are not committed to long-term you're
making long-term decisions with a
short-term person
okay and if i have long-term commitments
then that might change things i guess
this is sort of like the deciding point
uh
yeah i don't know i don't know if you
guys call it how old are you
21. yeah i don't know if you guys call
it this anymore but when my kids were
like teenagers they call it the define
the relationship oh yeah conversation
that's the thing yeah and i that was
that was new to me even then i was old
so but um
it's definitely new to me now but that
that's kind of what we're having here is
you know
you know the only way i'm going over
there is if we you're going over there
and if you break up when you're overseas
that's awkward